I mean in Ronda Rousey's case it was
also it was very much yeah her mom was a
world judo champion her mom was a beast
she's had an interesting path I think
yeah yeah I'm wondering how much she
loves the WWE I wonder I always wonder
when a person is like an elite athlete
at the highest level everyone a real one
if they they still enjoy doing that
because I think she enjoyed it though I
think she was a fan of it before she
liked the theater of it yes I think she
actually enjoyed pro wrestling you know
and they are doing athletic things even
though it's scripted obviously flying
off of an into and around oh yeah I mean
it's athletic but it's scripted yes it's
not competition but then again you could
only get knocked unconscious so many
times you can only get fucked up so many
times and she got fucked up two fights
in a row I'm really bad the Holly Holm
Kos is ruthless that was brutal and then
Amanda Nunez just punched her face in
for 48 seconds it was horrific
yeah that was hard to watch I don't like
to watch I mean I don't like to watch
really big guys punch each other and
women I don't know why I like when guys
are a little smaller it's easier to
watch as long as they're not kicking
themselves in the head
I'm just saying so the big scary ones
like heavy weight you just go oh my god
I just that guy took eight years off
that guy's you know yeah it's definitely
different you do notice it like there's
certain heavy weights and they hit guys
and they get knocked unconscious whether
it's Francis and Ghana or steep Amy oh
Chooch or these big guys and they slam
someone's like oh my god that's what I
mean like I watch that I don't actually
I mean violence I know it's sport but
for me it's oh it's violent it is yeah
it's a it is a very dangerous path that
you have to know when to get off and
more I don't know if I would say more so
than other combat sports but yeah it
makes all of them Oliver have a path but
I think very specifically MMA has you
have to be really careful because the
consequences are so great there's not
enough padding in those gloves or tiny
little things you could also get kicked
you can get need in the face elbowed in
the face and once you realize the chin
starts going
your reflexes start going and you're
slowing down like you gotta get out now
yeah you got to get out yeah and
sometimes they don't get the proper
advice you know and sometimes they don't
know what else to do they don't have
anywhere else to go
and that goes back to yeah I was talking
I talked to Larry about that because we
have tons of friends and organized
sports so if like you have to be drafted
or coach the team has to pick you up or
you know whatever and I say to him like
how fortunate are you that you're in a
sport like other athletes like a
snowboarder or whatever that you can go
yeah you can go out yeah you want a ride
you can go right nobody's dictating to
you